william atherton you'll hear at
collector mania I read that your
Ghostbusters character you got kind of
in fights on the street and things
because people kind of couldn't
disassociate you from your character is
that right no I never got a fight on the
street I got I got people who couldn't
believe I was walking down the street
with him on the street in New York
particularly but no I never got eyes
with anybody that way I had I had a
couple of you know the funny times to
the Walter Peck kind of thing when I was
I remember I was I was in a
the hotel basement with a couple of
people looking at some wires in somebody
came saw me there thought that was very
odd so that was about the only time see
yeah you mentioned the 30th anniversary
of ghostbusters and there's talk that
they're gonna make the Ghostbusters
three would you be on board to come back
to this of course of course I mean
everybody would it's a wonderful picture
it's a wonderful movie but the first one
is really a signature cultural event and
it would depend that would depend you
know on lots of things Harold isn't here
anymore Ivan is bill is so we'd all have
to see I guess